um we thought that would be the best way
to go about doing things vers someone
sitting behind bars and um we are a
society that truly know that
um jail is not really a
deterrent but um if there's someone that
I don't think I think somewhere in here
doesn't it talks about you know
subsequent offenses we wouldn't expect
someone that's going to continue to do
the same thing over over again to be
afforded this opportunity this is more
opportunity for um someone that hasn't
offended um over and over again or
whatever and that allow them to be with
their caretakers because there's a
disruption all around in terms of
whether it's your children or someone
that you're caring for so that's the
Ence up
it thank you any uh
members of the public that want to
speak oh I'm sorry representative that's
okay thank you
um I I I have very mixed feelings about
this bill I in theory I think it's a
great idea um I absolutely believe that
we should be doing whatever we can to um
minimize incarceration um you know we
for all the reasons that we know there
there are challenges around that um my
concern um as a former employee of the
state's child protection system um are
around um that Aces not only involve
violent crimes but there are other
impacts to Children um and this this
this well vulnerable um populations
maybe the disabled Community um that I
don't know that are necessarily
protected by this um one of the the
um things that I noticed I don't think
when we're talking about Primary Care
Giver um you know we're not talking
about sometimes you know a custody I
mean I don't think that's necessarily
addressed here U whether or not that
person has custody um
and I don't know I I feel like it needs
a little work um and I and I don't know
um given the input that we that we had
from some of the um the stakeholders it
it it specifically at least as it stands
right now I understand it doesn't
address if the vulnerable person is the
victim um and that my understanding also
was that
um uh the judicial system already has
the ability to um impose lesser
sentences and I and I having worked in
the system and with some parents that
you know were struggling with substance
abuse challenges I absolutely um agree a
um somebody testified that even though
they have the ability sometimes there's
bias and I I wholeheartedly acknowledge
that and I think that's a reality um
but you know I'm not I'd be interested
in seeing if there are things that we
could do to address those concerns uh
because as as as is um it I don't know
that I think we have to be conscious of
balancing the rights and the protections
and the well-being of the vulnerable um
disabled and children with do doing the
right thing for uh for parents who who
who need
help thank you so there was a Senate
Bill last year I believe SP 254 that is
similar to some of this bill almost
verbatim I think uh the new bill
obviously there was quite a bit added to
it probably to maybe answer some of the
concerns the senate had with it it was
killed in the Senate um my opinion is it
it may have made it worse course I think
there are some things in it that might
be confusing it might actually open the
door for judges
sending people back into the homes to
revictimized to make it workable for
where all parties are are happy with it
but
uh I'm willing to listen to any other
any testimony about if anyone from the
public wants to speak on what your
concerns
were I may have a question for attorney
Enders um just so I can refresh my
memory on something you may have
testified for last
time and and I don't I I agree that the
bill has some has some Merit I just
think
uh it's it needs a lot of work and I
think it's going to cause more damage
than it is good um so I guess a question
I have is was it this bill that you
spoke that the nine the nine County
attorneys and there you were all on
board with it is this was it this bill I
no okay that's what I wanted to clarify
okay so any anything that you you tell
us or you told us in testimony was was
yours no I would indicate that again in
New Hampshire everyone obtains an
individualized
sentence
um one of the things I would draw the
attention to is RSA 6514 B and that that
statute is entitled PR sentence
investigation of members of and Veterans
of the Armed Forces it essentially says
when a defendant appears in court and is
convicted of a crime the court shall
inquire whether the defendant is
currently serving in or is a veteran of
the Armed Forces and then it goes on to
say if the defendant is currently
serving in the armed forces or is a
veteran and has been diagnosed with
having a mental illness by a qualified
psychiatrist the court May and it goes
on but essentially says consider the
treatment recommendations of any
diagnosing or treating mental health
professionals together with the
treatment options available to the
defendant in imposing sentence and I
think that's the gist of what this bill
wants to accomplish for
caregivers not necessarily
veterans and I I think almost less words
might be more in the sense of saying um
the court can take into consider
consideration an individual status as a
caregiver prior to imposing
sentence
um and again I think the court can do
that now but I think maybe making it
more explicit would be uh what what the
drafters are looking for and at least to
let the court know that and
again everyone in New Hampshire gets
gets an individualized sentence and it
certainly welcome anybody to come over
to Superior Court and watch sentencing
it's their public hearings and you can
certainly see what the court talks about
and goes through when making those uh
sentencing decisions okay so would it be
your opinion
that what this bill is trying to
accomplish is already being done or can
be done with the existing legislation I
I I would say it's already being done on
on a daily basis that I I know certainly
as a prosecutor negotiating sentences
with defense counsel
if someone is a parent or a caregiver
that's almost always brought to my
attention that because defense is using
that as a mitigating factor to say
please don't send this person to jail
because they have kids they have a job
they have an apartment they have you
know people they're taking care of
whether that argument wins the day or
not is is a separate issue certainly
it's something that is taken into
consideration and in your opinion is
that basically the essence of this bill
is just allowing I guess a judge in this
case to consider those things not
necessarily rule that
way that's how I read this bill um there
is a list of
specific treatment or options in a to J
of what the judge can potentially
impose really a lot of those options are
available in every case to the extent
they're available at all and I say to
the extent they're available at all in
the sense of um I think it's difficult
to find some of these programs because
they're not statun they're not funded
programs okay you had a question
about uh constitutionality I guess of
sentencing without knowing what the S
sentence is going to be that vagueness
yes I I had those concerns with respect
to paragraph three I think there's a way
it can be done that's constitutional
and and I don't want to be misunderstood
that I think there this is a complete
dead end I think it just needs a little
tweak with the wording essentially that
the court can
um you know suspend sentences require
people to appear for future review
hearings and um Can impose the sentence
at those
hearings thank you anyone have questions
representative
Newman yeah my question is I agree that
this this bill has Merit but I also
think that there are too many lists I
think they try to they try to cover
everything and um when you get a list
invariably you leave something out and
then they try to define or it appears
that that the SP the bill is trying to
Define what a judge can and cannot do so
now you've put handcuffs on the judge
and you may not have put in things that
that he should be able to do but can't
do because now they're confined to
whatever is in the list so I would have
difficulty supporting the current
wording of this bill well and I don't if
you have a comment on that thank you and
just to to follow up on that I also one
of the things that we have difficulty
with is you'll have a judge who will
look at this and say well it says I can
provide drug and alcohol treatment for a
person who's a caregiver and they may
interpret that to mean I can't provide
drug and alcoh call treatment to a
person who's not a caregiver because it
it it's not
explicitly given to them so I I do think
you run a you know
potentially a concern with that as
well representative uh hary thank you um
yeah the carv outs was one of the the
issues that I had um concerns about just
you know in an attempt to to make ensure
that certain things were left out I I
just worry that some that may be equally
important are not considered um I
actually I really like the idea of this
bill and I agree that it has has great
Merit um you know when I when I was
listening to the testimony and you know
reading the specifics um of the language
to me this is a a bill that is such a
great reminder to us of um we need to
invest we need to to fund programs um so
that we allow um the court
to have options I mean it's one thing to
say yeah we want to send somebody to
whatever treatment um and but if there's
no spots to put that person in um we're
doing a disservice to to the individual
um we're not meeting the family's needs
um we're not you know then the the
consideration of the impact of Aces on
um the children of incarcerated parents
aren't really being weighted properly so
I think this is just a real lightning
kind of call to say hey we've got to
fund programs to give the you know the
the Judiciary options um and you know
and you know address things like the the
all the precursors to to the challenges
that that you these individuals are
winding up on whether it's mental health
substance abuse um and you know we want
to you know the in a number of
situations just in my history with the
division I was the nurse I wasn't a
child protection a service worker but
you know the children that we're talking
about very often had um adverse
childhood experiences unrelated to the
the criminal um issues that we're
addressing here um and and we need to be
able to do something about that too so
it's a huge issue I I like the idea I
like the intent um I'm just you know if
the thought is that the ability to to
for the um the court system to already
do this um exists then we don't re need
to you know Rel legislate that but I you
know I would certainly love it if we
could um you know training for judges as
to you know hey please make this your
first consideration and then whatever um
and you know use this you know this this
goal U as a way to drive forward you
know options for you know I mean it me
so many meet needs it meets the needs of
the children meets the needs of the
parents it meets the needs of the courts
the you know the prisons and so um I
don't know this just some my
thoughts yeah I mean
I
thank you
for I'm Paul howon County attorney from
Mari County um I'd like to elaborate on
a couple things attorney endress
mentioned uh in no particular order pres
sentence
investigations many people don't know
but I was a defense attorney before I
became a prosecutor back in the early
2000s and they routinely did PR sentence
investigations on felony offenses back
in the early part of the 2000s uh they
were quite helpful uh at times because
they delve into issues such as those
raised within this statute probably
close to I'm going to bet about 10 years
ago or so um the PSIs uh started getting
used less and less and less and less to
the point now where I think they the the
virtual uh uh the Rarity uh is a prenten
investigation although it's still
allowed by statute uh and I think that's
an important tool but along those lines
I don't think that the the Department of
Corrections um is at the same Staffing
levels that may allow them to to
complete those so it comes back to a
funding of a program issue uh to get the
information in front of a judge um there
are some specialty programs throughout
um throughout in marac County as well as
in other counties for misdemeanor issues
marac county has a mental health court
uh but it's only at the at the Circuit
Court in conquered um Rockingham County
has a veterans court in the felony world
where we can refer people we can
transfer a case for with a negotiated
disposition over to Rockingham and get
it into the U veterans court and that
veterans court has access to housing um
VA Medical Care issues um uh uh
counselors for individuals a whole
laundry list of of available programs
but it's one location and it all comes
down down to funding of those individual
um individual programs marrat County
House of Corrections has a whole list of
uh programs that are available for
people that are incarcerated as well as
those that are under supervision within
the county they talk everything from
case management religious substance
abuse mental health medical assisted
treatment for drug use electronic
monitoring anger management uh addictive
thinking programs uh Narcotics Anonymous
alcohol uh Anonymous Work Release pro
programs those are all available
but those are all again driven by driven
by funding and we're lucky in Marat
County we have a pretty robust system uh
for that within the House of Corrections
here but again those only address
misdemeanor or House of Correction
sentences thank you representative
bden I hope I understand correctly that
the format in a subcommittee is that I
don't necessarily need to be asking
questions of witnesses and that this is
a conversation between the committee
members um on that
note um when we were working on this
language which we did spend quite some
time on um I was under the impression
and I think other stakeholders were
under the impression that the Tennessee
language that we modeled this on was
complex and I distinctly remember
looking it up reading it working to
model our language off of that but make
it more appropriate
realistic and um so I went to look that
up in preparation for this hearing and
realized that somehow it became
one one sentence and that sentence that
was added to Tennessee law and I'm not
sure when this happened I don't know if
they passed that complex version because
I don't know how to use their website
necessarily but it just says available
community- based alternatives to
confinement and the benefits that
imposing such Alternatives May provide
to the community should be considered
when the offense is nonviolent and the
defendant is the primary caregiver of a
dependent child and I think they were
saying um that it's probably too
specific should be more broad um I do
think that as a general role broad is
better than specific I I definitely
worked with the stakeholders to make it
less specific than they were asking um
but I you know I don't I'm just sharing
that I I feel like that could be an
alternative version of this bill but I
was also thinking of just handing
I asked um our committee researcher to
give us all copies of this but instead
he put one copy in my folder in my
filing cabinet that I haven't looked at
in like a year so I just realized it was
in there but if I gave this to you maybe
you could consider how you how you think
it fits into the mold of of how things
work right
now and I think this details into what I
had said earlier with reference to 6514
B with with reference to Veterans is
broader maybe better just to say um the
court can certainly take into
consideration whether or not a person is
uh the primary caregiver of a dependent
child in a nonviolent
offense and that should be in an
inclusive list not an exclusive list um
you know um to allow that to be an
inclusive list among other factors that
a court ought to consider not an
exclusive list of
one thank you and again I just come back
to this question of if it's
already the policy and it's already in
law and it's already being done what's
the point of making another law just to
reinforce
that I guess that's my question
representative
Balden I think that there may be a
practical
but I'm not an attorney so maybe they
have a different perspective but I think
there may be a practical difference
between
um directives that a judge is aware they
should be considering during um you know
the Jus the criminal justice process
versus an argument that an a hired
attorney available only to certain
people with certain funds would know
that they could successfully make based
on their experience in work their
knowledge of the judge their knowledge
of case history I think that
that's you know what I'm saying I feel
like that's the difference is that if we
make it clear that this is acceptable
perhaps it would be considered more
frequently um and applied to the folks
that we're trying to Target which are
the folks that while under the law
should be facing
incarceration aren't a threat to the
public and have dependence who would be
adversely affected by their
incarceration but I think it was
testified to that it's already in law
that this is to be considered that way
so we'll be making a new law just
to reiterate what another law says am I
Am I
Wrong there's nothing currently
explicitly in the law saying that the
court has to consider whether a person
is a a a uh caregiver for a dependent
child but certainly the court can
consider that under current law and I
think would consider that under current
law if it was brought to the Court's
attention and and just to follow up we
had talked about people facing
incarceration at least in New Hampshire
the Constitution um guarantees everyone
who's facing potential incarceration the
right to an attorney so if they can't
afford one they'll be appointed one by
the new through the New Hampshire public
defender office um and as I'm sure
you're aware the New Hampshire public
defender office is the the largest law
firm in the state of New Hampshire and
it has very talented dedicated attorneys
working there I've worked with some of
them representative will did you want to
speak on this Bill
yes Mr chairman I just wanted to say
that uh I definitely respect all the you
know there's some Nuance that needs to
be met here when it comes to this bill
but I do just think based on the fact
that this isn't currently in law that
despite the fact that respect that the
judges are probably good people and a
lot of them probably do take this into
account especially in Marram County just
because we got this guy here right now
but I do think that there's a concern
that exists from people that have gone
through the court system right now that
some of those judges because of not any
necessar we can get into the biases in
another place but because of uh the
history that people have are sort of
just getting these cases and then
sending them through with without
consideration and I think having
something in law that makes sure that
there is that consideration that the
judge says to themselves okay I have to
listen to RSA 6 whatever whatever
whatever because I have to make sure
that there's uh due consideration here
for somebody who might be a primary G
caregiver or something like that for
someone else so that that would be the
only thing that I have to say to
that representative
B thanks again um in response to the um
note that was made about the right to an
attorney I think it's worth taking into
consideration that in um there are many
cases I would say a large majority of
cases that never go to trial there's a
plea deal and um I I'm sure that if we
could obtain any statistics on the
reasoning used in um accepting a plea
deal that's offered that the ability um
like that the impact of the length of
incarceration on their lives or the
lives of dependence would be a factor
for the person deciding whether or not
to accept a plea deal like if I take
this to court I'm going to be in jail
pre-trial for God knows how long I could
lose my kids but my mom can take them
for three months if I just do three
months and I plea this out and that's
the kind of situation that comes to mind
when we're talking about making sure
that judges whether they're reviewing uh
what kind of sentence to apply in
something that went to trial
where someone had an attorney whether
they paid or whether it was a um a
public defender but as well as
situations where someone's taking a plea
deal they're going to end up in a in
front of a judge regardless the judge is
going to ask them do you understand um
what you're playing to Etc and so in
those situations where someone might be
especially because someone who's taking
something to trial is either I would
imagine extremely confident of their
innocence or um is moneyed in a
situation you know to the extent that
they're able to challenge that and I'm
not talking about people that are
innocent I'm talking about people with
this bill that are guilty that are under
the law deserving of incarceration and
that um so the odds that they're going
to end up obtaining a public defender
and taking it to trial I think are
incredibly small for the group of people
that are targeted by this legislation
and so the idea is that when they go
through that sentencing process for a
flag to pop up and say to the
judge the legislature which has
authorized the courts to exist agrees
and supports the judge if they want to
um assess some kind of sentence that
doesn't involve incarceration because of
the outlays of the people affected by
that person being incarcerated um you
know because like I in that example my
mom can take the kids for three months
but that's it um those types of
situations I think there should be a
conversation it should be taken into
consideration we don't want kids going
through the system we don't want kids
with trauma that are going to end up
being repeat offenders when they're
adults we don't want more people on um
relying upon government benefits that
are necessary and um you know it just
seems like a fiscally responsible choice
that if a judge definitely agrees that
someone can be reformed without
incarceration that we go that route
because there's just massive expenses
around incarceration not just to house
and feed someone who's being
incarcerated
but then to deal with the people that
they're no longer able to care for so if
if there are people in this state who
are guilty of crimes and who can be
reformed without incarceration we should
be looking at that regardless of however
we get there I'm cool with that um but I
feel like this paragraph um in Tennessee
law might seal the
deal representative Stone thank you as a
individual not a member of this
committee I'd like to State individual
Stone individual Stone
I'd like to say that I would assume in
my experience which was 25 years roughly
uh most judges understand Judiciary
discretion when it comes to sentencing
and most of these cases are pled out and
they are represented by Attorneys at
both the misdemeanor and felony level
and a good majority I would say what
probably 95% or more are plea deals
versus actual trials and the
representation from the public defenders
or a private attorney operates in the
best interest of the client to bring
these mitigating circumstances to the
table when it does come to incarceration
uh I think the sentencing guidelines do
exist for a reason and I just I just
can't imagine a judge uh going off the
reservation as you will to say that uh I
I have seen judges refuse to accept plea
deals but it's very very seldom in my
experience I don't know if attorney
henders could elaborate on that but very
rarely I think you do see judges that
are just flat out re receive the uh plea
deal between both
parties point out thank you let me point
out within
6512 in the annotated statute there's a
foot there's a section of footnotes
under section four it talks about the
discretion of the court and one of the
footnotes says this section referring to
the sentencing section of the statute
demonstrates A continuing intent by the
legislature to provide the sentencing
judge with options to to adapt his or
her sentence to a particular individual
in the manner best suited to accomplish
the Constitutional objectives of
punishment re abilitation and deterrence
and it refers to an individual case um
in
2022 there was another case most recent
one it looks like uh that is cited in
the notes and it says trial judges have
brought Authority Under This section to
provide for extended terms of of
imprisonment a range of fines probation
and conditional or unconditional
discharge and refers to a 2022 case so
the courts have acknowledged that they
that they understand they're they're
sentencing U
uh
flexibility uh and that's been repeated
throughout many of the footnotes and I
don't know if the committee has U access
to those footnotes but I can certainly
provide those after the after the
hearing and that specifically sense says
that's the intent of the legislation so
the judges know that that's what our
intent is I'd have to look at the actual
case this is an extract from from the
case but the extract is is clear that
this section referring to 651 two which
is entitled um
entitled sentences and
limitations and it clearly says within
the parameters sent uh I'm sorry uh this
section demonstrates A continuing intent
by the legislature to provide the
sentencing judge it goes on from on from
there thank
you representative Murphy oh thank you I
was wondering could you read that um the
uh was it what state was it the little
blur that you have that was proposed
could you read that again available
Community Based alternatives to
confinement and the benefits that
imposing such Alternatives May provide
to the community should be considered
when the off when the offense is
nonviolent and the defendant is the
primary caregiver of a dependent
child thank you could you could would
you understand that to mean um not just
the community but to the dependent child
or the um the what whatever a disabled
adult or elderly parent is it just
considering the the community or are we
also considering the best interest of
the the the
child I read that to mean both okay that
um if there is a suitable Community
Based alternative to
confinement
uh that would benefit both the primary
caregiver and the dependent child then
the court should consider that thank
you anyone else in the public want to
speak on this
bill if you have anything to add more I
guess we uh your position still the same
on it
yeah you can come on up yeah
and feel free to join me if you want um
but I think a group of us um met this
morning um specifically focusing on the
child protection component I do think um
you know our position on this has been
pretty unwavering just because it's been
hard for us to picture what a an easy
fix to this legislation would be um we
agree that there is Merit and this is
something that should be explored um but
I think like even just the term
nonviolent in that I think that language
is so close but just knowing the
complexities that we've had in
addressing you know what it like what
does it mean to actually be a violent
crime when it could actually be a
harmful act like loudness and indecent
exposure isn't considered a violent
crime like is it you know is there a
physical injury component of it and
that's what makes it a violent crime
then that would leave out a lot of
things so I think you know I think if
there's an opportunity to continue to
explore this to look at how this could
fit in and I also just wanted to Echo
the funding component of it to make sure
that the adequate resources and services
are there so that we really are setting
Folks up for Success um I think just
wanted to Echo those things so I think
in brief yes our position is the same
but um we're happy to continue to have
these
conversations did you sorry oh no and uh
like uh Pam was saying we did meet this
morning and we are very open to uh
discussing how we can um work together
and figure out how we can make this bill
um um a more better suit and fit to make
sure we support them and what they feel
um that this bill can be better so
having conversations like we did this
morning having a subcommittee and
speaking with you guys would be really
good so yeah
absolutely yeah okay I'm just going to
say that when we heard this bill in our
hearing one of the things that I ask is
that we come together to see how um we
can get this bill in a passable um you
know and um and attorney Andre and Andes
and um Pam and um I believe it was Grace
at the time um I thought would come
together to to figure some of this out
that whole laundry list that's here in
for me I would have preferred that it
just said
nonviolent and this is our violent crime
for the State of New Hampshire it tells
you all the difference so I think
carving it out probably wouldn't work
for us because we're leaving something
out and um the other on on children I
like that idea I mean but I do believe
this bill is has a lot of Merit I truly
believe that and um even when we list
like the um drug and alcohol treatment
anger management
um I don't think we even need to do that
I just believe that we there's so many
different Services out there some are
Citywide or or or based on where you
live I know we don't we um marac County
seems to have a lot going on that's
great Hillsboro County which is where I
live have we have a lot going on but not
enough and but we do have different
organizations like take Nashua that
actually everything that's listed here
there is someone or somewhere that you
could refer so for me to have a bill
like this I think is great I think it it
also keeps in mind with the um with the
court system that these things are here
you know and people people really do
have a problem and but we can solve
their help them to solve their problems
you know as long as it's not violent or
something that affected a child or all
the things that Pam just just name I
don't think it's
that when I listen to some of you speak
I I I feel like what's so difficult
about this
bill and I just don't see it I really
don't see the difficulty that folks are
having with making certain
changes I think it's because there's a
lot of changes in there there and a lot
of them have some adverse effects
whether it's unknowingly or not but uh I
think it's might be too big too wordy
but it doesn't but and at the same time
doesn't include a lot of stuff so
representative
Balden in crafting the language we did
um the stakeholders who uh participated
in crafting the language many were
invited but those who participated um we
discussed uh whether or not the options
that someone could be that a judge could
assign would be attainable and um I
think it's worth noting that like with
therapy for example um the CRI Criminal
Court isn't the only Court where you
could be ordered to go to therapy um it
definitely happens in the family court
system as far as uh estranged parent
child
relationship um you know maybe someone
who has anger issues as it relates to
their family so it's not the first time
time and I'm not just spitballing like I
unfortunately know firsthand that it
didn't I wasn't assigned anything but it
is possible to for a judge to say you
have to go to therapy um and when
demands like that are made we do already
have systems in place in the state to
make sure that that's attainable such as
um expanding Medicaid there is a wide
variety of um mental health providers in
the state um and I certainly in my own
life have never had trouble finding one
that accepted my insurance and I've
certainly recommended it to lots and
lots of people because I do think
therapy is a really good choice in life
and I haven't really observed other
people having difficulty if you have a
really obscure insurance provider or a
bad plan you know it may be financially
limiting but that'd be something that
the court would need to take into
consideration and so as far as the
availability of Services they don't need
to be publicly provided they don't need
to be publicly funded um they don't need
to be coming from a a program um the way
that the bill is worded it's just you
you need to do these things to take care
of your life to work on improving
yourself so that you're not going to be
in front of a judge in trouble for
something
else anyone else have anything to had
yeah I have a question um when you guys
met this this morning okay um did you
come up with anything so um there was uh
the office of the child advocate we
point um ourselves and then um Miss
Bernett and Miss Ki and then uh did I
miss anyone and Amanda oh and R balen um
and I think like we were all in the same
quandry um we all Express like again
that this has Merit but none of us had a
direct recommendation I know the
question was posed well what is the
population that's trying to be served
here and do we start with a list of
crimes that like were that are specific
or do we look at you know modeling
something off of or attaching something
to drug court and mental health court I
think it's just a question of where we
can start maybe from a pilot um and then
grow go from there but there was no no
one had a an easy fix to this bill that
would satisfy by all of the concerns
that have been brought up especially
from a child protection angle um because
there's just too many opportunities I
think to forget something when we're
rushing to move forward on a proposal
when there's just a lot that really
needs to be considered so I think that's
kind of where we were coming from from
that lens I think if we had a solution
we would have proposed it months ago but
I mean and that's kind of why the bill
last session I don't think was able to
move forward either um because I I think
it just needs we need to look at this in
a in a very different way um also some
of the things that we um talked about
was um maybe instead of having a long
list of things that um you couldn't be
eligible for this bill or maybe coming
up with things that you would be
eligible for um also another thing that
I brought up this morning was if someone
previously had to sign onto the registry
or had a chased before of neglect and
they got their child back and they were
up for another case would they be able
to um be able to be eligible for this
bill now so that was something else that
we talked about um and um I also talking
about maybe talking to people about drug
cord and mental health um programming to
probably add to this and things like
that and educating judges on trauma
informs and things like that so we
talked about a few things and like I
said um previously just maybe I don't
know how many sessions we have like this
that we can have or how much time we
have left to have more um meetings that
we could talk about how this can work
better for both parties but we we
definitely talked about a few things but
I don't know how much time we have to be
able to discuss this bill of making it
better for
everyone um I know I don't think we have
a whole lot of time we have a lot of
bills in committee um and I think
continuing subcommittee meetings for a
few months I think we're going to run
out of time with it but um I think we're
on the right
path um representative Murphy thank you
um I think if it's determined that this
this bill is necessary if we need to
further clarify what's already in
statute um I would be opposed to listing
non-violent offenses as the qualifier um
because I think there are things that I
just think of many years in child
protection and as moms whether
somebody's you know going to be
incarcerated or not that doesn't say
anything necessarily about their ability
to parent but it doesn't take into
consideration things like criminal
neglect um
exploitation um the vulnerable person as
the victim so you know um time is one of
the challenges I you know I I think that
this bill has great Merit but I think
that broader approach is a better thing
if it's determined that it's necessary
um because I think when we start getting
into qualifiers and you know we can only
we can only prescribe so much where a
judge you know we have to allow them
discretion and and um you know and and
again that goes back to my my thoughts
about funding the programs and training
for for for judges um so that this is
prioritized as as a need but I just I'm
just really want to be really cautious
about not fur further exacerbating
adverse childhood experiences for
children in an effort to provide a
caretaker um and I think we I think you
can do that um but I I don't I just
don't know in the time frame you know
and I I mean I think that's one thing
that you guys would have to talk about
and just my input yeah I agree I think
in order to craft this properly like you
said without rushing it without missing
something just in the essence of time
here to get this through this this
session I think this this might be
better being worked on with all parties
and getting something that's going to
work for for next perhaps rep
representative
bden it it is possible and has been the
practice in this committee and years
pass and other committees in the house
to have multiple subcommittee meetings
on a bill um as long as they're properly
noticed we can plan several in advance
and work offline or rather just outside
of the subcommittee room in between
those meetings um so as long as they're
properly noticed we can meet you know we
can schedule four more meetings and then
if we resolve it next time cancel the
rest and that just would need to be
noticed and um but I don't think that
four more meetings is necessary because
um I I think I feel confident personally
that if I could obtain any in writing
outlining
um the entirety of what the Coalition is
seeking uh for changes to this bill
something that I've repeatedly asked for
over 4 months um then it would be I
think fairly simple at least for me you
know with my experience reading
legislation and drafting legislation to
be able to incorporate that and I hope
to the greatest extent possible it's
always been my intent to work with the
Coalition on this and um incorporate
their views and in
particular um the Tennessee language
that we were moding after that I guess
ended up not being the language listed
certain crimes and we expanded the list
thereby excluding more people from
qualifying for this based on information
that ACLU obtained from some public
statement the Coalition made I think on
the issue of bail reform I I think that
might be it but the research that the
ACLU did is they said as far as we can
tell the Coalition is probably going to
want this to not be available to people
who've committed these and these and
these crimes and so the list is was in
the bill is longer than what was
originally introduced in Tennessee so it
has been our monthlong intent to work
with the Coalition and if they wanted to
produce any research or any
notes maybe via the text messages that
you know Pam has my number or on the
Google Doc that I sent her back in
September asking for her comments on or
just email me on my available email
address then I could Implement that
within a couple of days and have it
ready for the next subcommittee meeting
for all of us to
consider I appreciate that R balen and I
think with all due respect what we've
provided in writing and testimony last
session and this session is what we are
able to provide in terms of flags I'm
myself am not an attorney um I'm my
background is in looking at how we can
prevent trauma and violence and I've
given all that I can possibly give I'm
happy to continue to connect folks to
other entities that we know and work
with that could maybe inform like some
of the folks here in the room today but
I don't know what else to provide
to to inform this
process anyone else that wants to speak
on this
bill somebody behind
you
hi my name is gel I was here last
time
testify I know I just wanted
to I would just wanted to to address to
to like you know the the
opposition um so I keep hearing that
they they were saying that this bill
isn't really necessary because the
judges already have discretion and they
can they can already do these things but
if if they were doing these things then
we wouldn't need this bill this bill
wouldn't be necessary they wouldn't we
wouldn't have worked they would have
worked this time and and this hard
trying to get this right so that so that
it could pass if it was being done if it
was being
implemented um and I I also keep hearing
something about funding that that we
need to get funding and that they don't
have the the alternative sentencing the
other you know the places where they
would get some type of service instead
of
incarceration but that should not that
shouldn't be be something that's
preventing from passing this bill is
that they don't have funding for these
programs if anything then maybe this
would give them the push that they need
to start funding those program programs
but I don't think I think it would be a
disservice not to put this bill into
into effect based on that not being
enough programs or funding for all these
other alternative um Alternatives that
that are
presented um I keep hearing and I
also the um coalition's concerned with
the children and the children and
someone being returns back to you know
to to possibly harm the dependent or and
whatnot that's that's that's why we have
DCF if there's anything that's involving
the children that's harmful that or has
been caused harm to the children by the
primary caregiver then they're going
that's going to be um that's going to be
presented that's going to be there
because if there's dcyf involvement if
there's something that has to do with
the children their person got
incarcerated then that's that's going to
be without saying with it goes without
saying that dcyf is going to be in
charge that's what that's their that's
what their job is not not not this bill
or not anyone else so if if so the the
concern like it's kind of I don't
understand why that would be a concern
because also the same way that they say
that the judge has discretion now he
would he's going to also definitely have
discretion when considering this bill
and sentencing somebody according to
this bill because if if there is a
history or if there is something that on
there like she said criminal neglect or
or or whatever that's the you you best
believe the prosecutor is going to
definitely present that and then the
person's not going to be necessarily
won't be eligible for to for the bill
but that would be that would be because
of that so we shouldn't we shouldn't not
pass the bill because we want to protect
the children because that's what DCF is
for so if there's something that's
involving the children then they're
going to be involved they get involved
when they don't need to be involved so
they're going to definitely be involved
if there's something that's going to be
of concern so so much concern that they
wouldn't be eligible for this
bill so it's almost contradicting to say
that the judge has discretion now and he
can can do all this now and then in the
same sentence say that but if do they
have this bill and they have the
criminal history or they did this in the
past or they neglected their children um
they might get return back and Abus or
what or whatever you know what I'm
saying so it's you can't have it both
ways it's either one way or the
other
um
and and as and and as The Plea deals
because they brought up the plea deals
again they usually you know the judges
really uh you know they rarely don't
accept the plea deal but let's keep in
mind that the plea deal is presented by
the prosecutor it's not presented by the
people it's presented by the prosecutor
and they the people agree whether
they're going to take the deal or not
take the deal so that's not really being
worked out whether they are primary
caregiver or not
is I mean let's just be real they it can
be it's mentioned I'm sure it's
mentioned almost any almost every parent
that goes to court and is the parent is
responsible I'm almost positive that
that's one of the first things that they
say so again if it was if that was being
considered then we wouldn't be up here
presenting this bill because there
wouldn't be so many people who are in in
jail or in prison for uh for for for
those things instead of alternative
sentencing and then lastly um I wanted
to say
that ultimately I know this you know
this bill is for the primary caregiver
But ultimately it's for the people who
it's for the children or the dependant
who are affected by the primary
caregiver having to be incarcerated or
or
imprisons because if the the parent is
going to be away from their children for
however long they're the ones whether
they're with DCF or with family or
whatever the case may be but ultimately
like if speaking personally I'm an adult
I'm I'm I'm I'm grown already if if I
were to go you know to prison obviously
I'm going to be able to handle it a lot
better than the children going to be
able to handle it so they're the ones
who are going to ultimately suffer the
most not the not the person who's being
incarcerated so that and that's the
point of this bill is to stop that from
happening to to interrupt that pattern
of parents being and children to being
taken away from their parents and so on
and so
forth and um I believe that's all thank
you thank you representative
Balden thanks for calling on me so many
times without looking the least bit
exasperated um I think
probably the um uh giselli I think
brings up a good point that um in your
first comment that really could maybe be
phrased more concisely as like is this
bill going to do something and it'll do
bad things or is this bill already the
practice of the court and so those are
those seem to be um mutually exclusive
Concepts and I think it's important to
get down to the the facts of the
situation and I think that we have
established at this point that while
this is always an option it's not a
directive to the
courts and then there's just the debate
over if this was um a directive given to
the courts would it make bad things
happen and I and I think that Gil then
spoke to that um I think really well
that um we already have systems in place
to protect people from abusers I'm not
going to say that they're excellent
systems um but in if the goal of this
legislation as with any legislation is
to solve a problem then we need to be
able to rely on existing systems to
address any possible unexpected outlays
because the more specific we get the
more flawed it is and the broader it is
the more we open ourselves up to
unexpected situations so we have to
strike a balance there and I really
think that the one sentence in the
Tennessee law could do the deal
here okay representative M
Murphy yes um I know we talked about
time constraints and uh given um you
know what we've heard today and at the
public hearing and I think we've all
agreed that this there's Merit to this
bill um sometimes that doesn't happen
and and it's easy to
itl I would support um an additional
work session I think the um we have
stakeholders that are willing to be um
involved I think you know that Tennessee
bill today um in my mind at least is a
bit more appealing maybe with some
tweaks um you know I certainly think it
deserves consideration and you know at
least one more subcommittee uh hearing
to see if we could have an amendment of
the the um Prime sponsor could bring
forth an uh an amendment in conjunction
with the stakeholders that we could
agree on um and I I would just hate to
throw it away because it I in my mind it
needs a lot of work but I
think limiting things and making it a
little bit more General would actually
be helpful and um I I would support a uh
another committee work
session representative tenar I just like
to add that I concur with representative
Murphy on
that representative Bon
again or for the first time every seven
years all your cells get replaced who
knows what happened since I talked last
last I might be a different person now
but um yeah I'm reminded my neighbors
across the street um their
grandchildren um their their adult
son committed some crimes lost custody
of his children um the his uh the mother
also ended up in prison and the
grandchildren the uh my neighbors cross
street didn't have the opportunity to
get the grandchildren and they've since
been adopted out names changed no
contact they live somewhere in Florida
and that is what we're talking about
with like these there's a human child
right or a human dependent a person with
a severe disability an elderly parent
someone with dementia someone with
mobility issues who lives in this world
now and depends on a person for survival
and for to have their daily needs met
and the experience of that person either
having to figure out how to survive
without that person because they've been
incarcerated on something that in theory
we could address without incarceration
if this is narrow enough so either
having to survive without that person
which my mom would not be able to
function without me she doesn't seem to
be able to bring her dishes to the
kitchen without me but um you know or
they're going to end up in the care of
the state or and you know when you go to
a County Nursing Home in New Hampshire
um or you know some kind of nursing home
often the arrangement is that your
property is signed over to the county
and everything you work your whole life
to pay for it's not going to go to your
air is is going to go to the county for
sale and um you know or they're going to
end up in the system with new family
last name changed and there's all these
people in their lives that maybe they
could have enjoyed contact with Aunts
Uncles cousins uh friends that they were
in school with back home in New
Hampshire so those are the lives that
we're talking about here it's not about
giving someone passing the buck on an
abuser it's about someone who's valued
and needed by their family who should
have the opportunity to do that self-
reforming in an environment that also
enables them to keep delivering for the
people who depend on them if I
Disappeared
tomorrow my family would probably be
homeless or have to leave the state
within two months I mean it just
wouldn't work my kid wouldn't be in
college he's over at UNH Durham that
would go down the drain very quickly um
you know there's not enough coffee shops
and time in the world for him to work
out to be able to stay in school much l
you know spending money at record stores
and so these are real lives for talking
about this isn't um theoretical and and
I hope that we can focus on the people
and and again with the question
of it does this court have this
discretion now in the original public
hearing for this bill we heard written
testimony read aloud to the committee
from people in New Hampshire who were
incarcerated who had dependence and what
the impact was on the lives of the
dependents when those providers those
caregivers were incarcerated so this is
happening it's not being considered as
often as maybe the court should and I do
think that it is really important for
the committee to take action in some
regard and I'm more than happy to do all
the acrobatics and hard work myself
because I gave you this problem and I'll
deal with it but I want to make sure
that it's in coordination with all the
stakeholders and we get the maximum uh
buying and support possible and hear all
sides thank you and just because we
heard testimony of people who ultimately
were incarcerated doesn't necessarily
mean that discretion wasn't used and and
those things weren't considered
incarceration was just a decision by the
judge and I don't know the scenarios in
those cases so I can't really comment on
the Merit of it but we don't know that
whether discretion was used or not so I
believe we're in agreement unless anyone
else wants to speak that we'll have
another session I'll schedule another
session and see what we can come back
with uh for language if it if it
satisfies the group and we'll go from
there so I don't when we here next week
I'd like to put it on a day that we're
already here does that make sense rather
than come in on a special day
here I think we're only here on Friday
next week Friday yeah I'm looking right
now it's just Friday
Friday and the last bill is 12 so if we
schedule it for one Friday 2 or I try to
schedule it for for one with Karen and
see what we have is that enough time to
you think a week to put together
something that you think everybody would
can work
with yeah if the if I'm provided the
information that all the stakeholders
know I've been requesting I'm sure we
can work something out and I think the
issue with that single that simpler
Tennessee language was the nonviolent
part of it so we come up with something
we can work on it next week Jer Manion
yes um 1 pm doesn't let the committee m
do lunch though if we have the last bill
at 12 then you are correct so do
people look tzar is the perfect example
we need it we need at least an hour for
lunch 2 p.m. maybe what about a brown
bag subcommittee meeting you know they
say we can't eat in this building but
they can't stop all of us right so what
so I guess we can all agree the four of
us who are going to be adversely
affected by it um what do we agree on
for a Time One 2 o'clock so you want to
have a lunch you want to do two does two
work two work for it's Friday night I
mean I don't know it's cut into my sleep
time a little bit CL isn't the deadline
to notify the clerk like 4:30 today or
something isn't it isn't the deadline on
Wednesdays to put something in the
calendar I'll check with is Karen still
here I'll check with her right now if we
can put it in right now for two o'clock
on Friday see if that works all right
excellent with that I will close the
session on House Bill